the following are agonizing problems
that all British people face not quite
catching someone's name meaning you can
never speak to them again receiving an
email ending in regards and wondering
what you've done to cause so much anger
the terror of these words in a minute
I'm just gonna ask you all to present
your ideas to the room the impossibility
of eating a jaffa cake without someone
bringing up that debate panicking in a
sandwich shop and allowing a
distressingly old combination of
fillings to happen not wanting to use an
emoticon yet worrying you'll come across
a sarcastic without one never wanting to
use an exclamation mark yet worrying
you'll come across as miserable without
one losing faith in your delivery
halfway through telling a joke so opting
to just explain what punchline was going
to be and why seeing someone you know
walking just ahead of you so stopping
dead in the street until they're
completely out of sight resigning
yourself to an unusual and arduous train
route rather than risk sharing the
commute with a colleague asking to
sample an ale disliking it and ordering
a whole pint so so not further waste the
barman's time feeling your life lacks
excitement so dunking your biscuit for
an irresponsibly long time saying
obviously it's fine to warm oven
Oh